Je me suis engagée en politique assez tôt
au début des années 70. Et mon engagement
militant a commencé avec la campagne
présidentielle de 1974 et l’élection
de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing. A
cette époque-là, j’avais 23 ans.
J’avais 18 ans. J’ai vu une émission
politique locale où une jeune fille
montait une liste pour les municipales. Je
me suis dit : bah tiens ! oui, j’ai envie !
J’ai eu envie de m’engager pour
ma commune. Je me suis dit : « et
pourquoi je ne me présenterais pas aux
prochaines élections municipales ? ».
J’ai répondu à un appel de François
Bayrou. Il voulait vraiment donner du
poids et de l’engagement à des
femmes. Et donc j’ai accepté,
et j’ai accepté comme un engagement
supplémentaire dans ma vie.
C’est une rencontre avec le Président
de la République, Emmanuel Macron qui
a déclenché mon envie d’oser faire,
ce que lui d’ailleurs osait faire.
Quand Emmanuel Macron, le 28 janvier 2017,
a fait un appel aux femmes en disant
: « les femmes, si vous ne candidatez
pas aux élections législatives l’Assemblée
nationale ne changera jamais de visage ».
Il y avait peu de femmes
en politique, donc en 2014,
je me suis engagée pour un mouvement citoyen.
J’étais petite, vraiment très petite
et j’étais déjà révoltée par le fait
qu’on jette du papier et qu’on ne recycle
pas. Donc j’ai écrit à 7 ans à mon maire,
je venais d’apprendre à écrire pour
lui demander de bénéficier instamment
d’un bac de collecte pour recycler le
papier. Et quelques années plus tard,
je devais avoir 12 ans, il m’a écrit pour
me dire que cela avait été enfin installé.
J’étais contente parce que j’avais 12 ans et
j’avais l’impression d’avoir changé le monde.
Je me suis engagée la première fois
véritablement pour les élections législatives,
donc c'était en 2017. Suite à la mort
de mon père, j'ai réalisé finalement à quel
point la vie était courte, à quel point il
fallait vivre ses rêves et prendre son risque.
Au cours de mes différents engagements,
j'ai eu l'opportunité de visiter certains
lieux. Toutes ces rencontres, tous ces lieux,
m'ont fait comprendre qu'il était important de
défendre des convictions, des valeurs, des
principes, notamment la paix, la liberté.
C'est en 2014, je crois. Je suis
passée devant les colonnades de
l’Assemblée nationale et j'avais déjà
en moi cette envie de m'engager. Et
devant les colonnades je me suis dit "là
Sandrine tu peux faire bouger les choses !"
Il y a des choses à faire pour les femmes et
des choses à faire aussi pour les Français.
Et pour aller plus loin ensuite - notamment
en devenant maman - j'ai voulu poursuivre
cet engagement, maintenant il se
fait aussi dans le cadre politique.
C'est plus compliqué pour une femme de
s'engager d'abord en terme d'attitude
probablement plus réservée, moins
sur le devant de la scène et puis
avec des contraintes. Le fait tout simplement de fonder une famille.
Une femme, elle peut pas faire que
sa carrière politique. Souvent il ya
des enfants et un conjoint. C'est
quand même différent d'un homme,
car madame souvent reste à la maison, s'occupe
des enfants et lui peut faire carrière.
Je conciliais, comme beaucoup de
femmes le font, vie familiale,
vie professionnelle et mon engagement politique.
Quelqu'un était venu me contacter pour les
élections municipales. J'ai été élue. Ce soir-là,
quand j'ai appris les résultats, je suis
rentrée chez moi, je me suis assise sur mon
lit et j'ai pleuré. Parce que je me demandais
comment - en tant que maman célibataire pour
le coup - j'allais pouvoir assumer ma tâche de
maman et puis ma fonction d'élue municipale.
Il y a une culpabilisation qui est mise sur
les épaules des femmes que je trouve absolument
insupportable. On n'a pas besoin de culpabiliser
les femmes parce qu'elles ne sont pas au foyer
en permanence, parce qu'elles ont elles aussi une
vie où elles s'épanouissent à côté. Au contraire.
J'avais bien en tête les difficultés que
pourrait rencontrer une femme dans un
milieu particulièrement masculin.
La preuve on m'a opposé que je ne
pourrais pas réussir en politique parce
que j'étais mère de quatre jeunes enfants.
Il y a beaucoup beaucoup de combats encore
pour les femmes qui méritent d'être menés,
et là en dehors de la vie politique,
tant dans la vie économique que sociale :
l'équilibre au sein de la vie familiale,
l'équilibre dans la vie professionnelle, l'accès
des femmes à certains postes à responsabilité...
C'est à nous de batailler et puis de prendre
notre place. Mais allons-y, engageons nous!
Si on ne fait rien, il y aura toujours plus
d'hommes que de femmes. Il y a par ce volontarisme,
particulièrement dans notre famille politique
et particulièrement de la part de Marielle,
qui a fait que toute une génération de femmes a eu
la chance de pouvoir s'engager
au sein de notre mouvement.
Femmes en politique, ça me fait penser à quoi ? Ca
me fait penser au 21 avril 1944 :
le droit de vote donné aux femmes.
La place de la femme dans la société est
évidemment quelque chose de très important.
Il a fallu des lois sur la parité
pour un peu accélérer le mouvement.
Femmes en politique ? Pas évident, parce qu'il
faut se faire une place et souvent la place est
déjà prise par des hommes pendant que nous
nous posons la question de notre compétence.
On se pose toujours la question nous les
femmes "mais est ce que je suis capable
d'y aller ?". Les hommes ne se posent pas de
question de savoir s'ils sont compétents ou pas.
Les femmes c'est 50 % de la population,
donc c'est une force formidable.
Beaucoup de gens se sont interrogés de sur le
fait de légiférer pour faciliter la parité.
Aujourd'hui je crois que le résultat
montre qu'on a eu raison de légiférer.
La loi sur la parité a permis l'émergence
de nouvelles têtes, de femmes. Et je sais
qu'à l'époque beaucoup d'hommes disaient
"il n'y a pas besoin d'une loi on le voit,
toi tu es là, pas besoin d'une loi pour
que les femmes arrivent en politique!".
L'égalité entre les femmes et des
hommes ça commence dans la famille,
ça commence par l'éducation.
Moi j'espère que l'éducation changera un peu pour
permettre justement l'émergence de
femmes qui ont envie de s'engager.
Qu'elles viennent apporter leur talent. Qu'elles
viennent apporter aussi leur façon quelquefois
un peu apaisée de construire et surtout
leur envie de construire positivement.
Alors je suis confrontée
au sexisme tous les jours.
Des mots sexistes bien évidemment j'en ai eus,
comme je pense, toutes les
femmes en ont déjà entendus.
Incompétente, invisible, inutile et...
Y'en a un autre... mais je l'ai oublié!
Les commentaires sur la coiffure sur les habits...
Ce sont des commentaires qu'on utilise justement
quand on veut disqualifier une femme en politique.
J'essaye de le vivre avec distance et humour!
Incompétente, invisible, inutile. Et?
Après effectivement parfois je
peux me fâcher un peu aussi!
Transparente, invisible, incompétente
et inutile : c'est ça voilà !
Ca peut être vexant, ça peut être déstabilisant.
On peut avoir des propos effectivement
ou des mimiques qui montrent un mépris...
Arrêtez les gars, ça suffit ! On est là. On est là
et vous ne pouvez pas nous effacer d'un
coup de gomme. Il faut faire avec nous!
Il a fallu lutter un petit peu à l'Assemblée
nationale pour se faire sa place. On a encore
énormément de collègues un peu
machistes. Ca commence à changer,
mais on voit qu'il ya encore
un petit peu de travail.
Et puis je pense que c'est très important
d'amener cette sensibilité féminine.
J'ai envie de dire à toutes les
femmes : osez franchir le pas,
notre société a besoin de femmes
qui s'engagent en politique.
Il ne faut pas avoir peur du combat.
Oui il faut que les femmes prennent la parole,
qu'elles prennent le pouvoir aussi.
Il faut qu'elles osent la politique !
Pour gagner en faveur des femmes.
Femmes, osez la politique!
Osez, osez tout.
Vous avez un petit plus que n'ont pas les hommes.
Mesdames, engagez-vous!
Engagez-vous pour trouver le sens, engagez-vous
parce que vous avez le droit de le faire.
J'incite toutes les jeunes filles,
toutes les jeunes femmes, toutes les femmes
même d'un certain âge à aller en politique!
Fonce, fais-toi confiance!
Femmes, osez la politique!